Das war's für heute.
Und ordentlich erklärt und eigentlich gibt es überhaupt nichts an diesem Video auszusetzen.
Eigentlich müssten das Video alle geil finden.
Ich meine, die Leute, die es gucken, scheinen es ja auch gut zu finden, die sich dafür
interessieren.
Und es ist ja auch heute angesagt.
Aber Leute wollen nicht.
Da fragt man sich doch, warum man dann wirklich ordentlichen Content, ach, noch ein Day in
the album, ja, perfekt, ähm, warum man ordentlichen Content machen soll, mach ich einfach, mach
ich einfach nur noch Battlefield-News-Videos, easy.
Mach ich einfach Battlefield-News-Videos jetzt, mach ich jede Woche zwei Battlefield-News-Videos,
gibt es genug Zeug und dann mach ich Level Cap 2.0 Sellout, easy Abos.
Äh, Regenwolf, ja, ich erklär das eigentlich ziemlich genau, ich mein, ein bisschen Vorkenntnisse
muss man schon haben über das Ganze.
So, hier kann ich mir mal eine Dande kaufen am 14., wird auch echt Zeit.
Easy Dandel.
Warum bist du traurig?
Weil ich mir so viel Mühe gegeben hab für das Video heute und das war eines der anstrengendsten
Videos, die ich hier aufgenommen hab, ja, zumal ich sogar mehrere Anläufe noch gebraucht
hab.
Und es ist sogar ein aktuelles Thema, das heißt, heute zu dem Thema noch wirklich ein
inhaltlich ordentliches Video zu machen, so ausführlich und so im Detail ist wirklich
nicht ohne gewesen, ja.
Ich mein, ich bin erst im Prinzip um 17 Uhr von der Arbeit gekommen, ich hab mehrfach
aufgenommen und insgesamt jetzt 28 Minuten Video hochgeladen bis jetzt, also ich hab
heute im Prinzip noch nichts gemacht, ich hab eben grad auch noch was gefuttert, nix
großartig gemacht, außer das.
Und ich mach jetzt auch wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen BDO-Stream, nix und was kommt
raus am Ende, also das ist nicht unbedingt jeder guckt, kann ich ja verstehen, aber gleich
erstmal 5D-Abos reingehauen, einfach mal so instant so, äh, scheiße, gefällt mir nicht,
kein Bock.
Also, ihr müsst mir jetzt kein Geld geben oder so, ne, aber wer hat denn gewusst, der
Woodpecker, 1,5,5,6,10,51, du bist der erste besten YouTuber, den ich kenne, ja, das höre
ich natürlich gerne so was, aber das nervt mich, weil mich das wieder zu dem Schluss
bringt, dass du eigentlich, wenn du irgendwas gefunden hast, von dem du merkst, oder sag
mal so, entweder findest du was, wovon du merkst, dass das gut ankommt und reitest
dann ewig drauf rum, oder du bist noch unkreativer und suchst dir was, was gut ankommt und reitest
dann immer drauf rum, so Reaction-Videos oder irgendwie sowas, im Prinzip will gar keiner
mehr ordentliche Sachen sehen, hab ich manchmal das Gefühl, echt, ich geb zu, meine Pain-Skills
sind jetzt echt nicht die besten oder so, aber zum erklären reicht das doch, und ich
hab sogar ein schönes Thumbnail gemacht, ja, ich hab mir, übrigens für Thumbnails, hab
ich mir Dings hier gekauft, wie heißt's, Affinity Designer, das ist echt gut, weil ich brauch
für Thumbnails ja keinen Photoshop oder sowas, das ist ja absolut overkill, oder auch kein
InDesign und sonst was, Affinity Designer ist super, wow, bisschen laut hier, der Klaviertyp,
hab ich mir gekauft, weiß nicht was gekostet, 69 Euro oder so, 50 Euro, sind wir noch so
laut, so, und wo war ich jetzt gerade stehen geblieben, keine Ahnung, ja, Affinity Designer
ist echt cool, äh, BDO ist ein bisschen leiser, ne, das ist eigentlich mein Gaul, lull, nicht
da, weiß nicht wo ich den abgestellt, ah da, da steht er doch, was ist das hier eigentlich,
ne? Ist das die neue Icons? Oh, Bufffood muss ich noch kaufen, Bufffood, richtig, Bufffood.
Ich glaub ich mach den Titel mal wieder anders, weil ich hab mich jetzt ja ausgeheult, jetzt
reicht's. Aber das geht mir echt auf den Sack. Oder man geht nach Japan und filmt die schönen
Oh was ein wie sie sich aufgeregt haben alle wieder
Ich habe das video übrigens nicht geguckt
Ich finde es überraschend dass ich bei de abos trüben was ist daran überraschend man gibt sich übelst mühe
Und leht was hoch was man selbst gut findet hat sich halt ist davon überzeugt gibt es mühe und sie ist erstmals finden leute scheiße
Ja was war warum soll mich das nicht bedrücken laut social plate hast du heute 33 abos gemacht richtig habe ich
Hab ich habe die letzten tage relativ viele abos gemacht
Aber was du auf social plate natürlich nicht siehst ist was ab dem upload zeitpunkt ist
Die abos habe ich ja heute vormittag gemacht
Ich stelle sie jetzt schon auf social plane um zu gucken ob das stimmt was ich erzähle oder was
Ich wollte food kaufen was muss ich machen
Ich wollte food kaufen was muss ich denn eigentlich mit food kaufen mit mediamin muss ich kaufen ich mach den titel mal anders ich mach jetzt mal in den in den
Ultima tiva daily quest jebait
Keine tippe gerade
Hat er jetzt den titel geht das backt übelst rum auf twitch nur ich erinnere den titel und erinnere den titel nicht auch geil
Die die die die die die
Die titel
Die titel die titel die titel
Die titel die titel magore ne media mediamin brauche ich da gift please
Ein sandburg tutorial würden sich wahrscheinlich mehr leute angucken und geil finden
Jetzt haben wir schon den ersten den ersten aussprache flamer am start
Der sich da drüber aufregt dass ich das das b oftmals als p ausspreche das mache ich eigentlich schon immer
Der hat jetzt noch gefehlt
Hi max weiß was ich weiß nicht warum aber ich bekomme ein pleck das hat immer nach kurzer zeit kopfschmerzen weißt du an welchen grafik einstellen was liegen kann ja macht das kameraschäkig aus
Kameraschäkig und die zauber effekte kannst du auch ein bisschen runter
Machen gift energy nice ja energy ist immer gut mach die wie gesagt macht die grafik ich zeig dir das gleich mal ich das bei mir hab
Ja guck mal mach die grafik ein
Ja guck mal mach die jetzt eigentlich der titel geändert war mittlerweile ja ok mach die mach die grafikeffekte hier unten also mach das hier weg
Kameraschäkig effekts effekts camera schäkig settings und das ganze scheiß macht das weg das nervt und effekt transparency auf 50 prozent das sieht dann ungefähr so aus wenn du wenn du ein bisschen mehr schäumst
Wenn du ein spell machst vom wizard sieht es dann halt auch so aus so leicht transparent es reicht dass du es siehst aber es ist nicht so in your face es reicht aber dass du siehst und was mir auch immer auf den zack geht ist das geschreie von den helden und das kann man hier auch irgendwo ausschalten weil hier irgendwie ich glaub das ist ein bisschen schwer
Und was mir auch immer auf den sack geht ist das ist das geschreie
Von den von den helden und das kann man hier auch irgendwo ausschalten
Weil hier irgendwie glaubt das ist weil in bdo schreien alle helden so übertrieben rum wenn sie irgendwas machen
Ja, ja das das verfahren gibt schon lange das hat aber im prinzip noch mehr overhead als das was ich erklärt habe was sie jetzt machen wollen
Im prinzip ist es ähnlich
Du musst halt jedes mal die komplette tabelle switchen serious max das ist natürlich noch mal ein bisschen
Es ist ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen
Anstrengender, ja aber im prinzip kannst du das so machen und so ähnlich machen sie es jetzt. Ja auch
Du schmeißt halt die ganze körner die die ganze körner geschichte
Wirfst du aus dem virtuellen adressraum für deine prozesse weg
Du schweißt halt die ganze körner die die ganze körner geschichte wirfst du aus dem virtuellen adressraum für deine prozesse weg
für deine prozesse weg
So ich wollte jetzt
Ich weiß eigentlich xm also der daily daily stills machen
Ich will auf das pferd steigen video lasst lasst mich auf das pferd steigen
So daily
Ich weiß mal ich verkaufe mal ich verkaufe den kramper noch mal wenn ich schon dabei bin
Erst mal alles schön einsammeln schon collecten wie in der kirche
Oder wie war toll collect
Kampel hier rein sagt sagt gucken dass ich nix nix falsches zähle
Gucken dass ich nix nix falsches zähle das behalten wir alles den scheiß weiß nicht ob wir das brauche
Das behalten wir alles den scheiß weiß nicht ob wir das brauche
Das leg ich mal in wald rein
Aber ich hab noch platz im ort ich mache heute einfach nur ein paar dailies ich eigentlich wollte ich das alleine machen aber ich hab mir gedacht hey
Wenn ich jetzt in ein paar dailies machen ein paar mobs kloppen dann kann ich einfach ausfrieben machen ein bisschen schwätzen
Beste labaustell
Okay, gehen wir mal hoch
Jetzt machen meine pets meine pets müssen
gefiedet werden
Ein bdo bist du immer erstmal mit 3000 sachen beschäftigt bevor du anfangen kannst
Asiak rein stellt halt
Rebe alle server anbieter die mit interl arbeiten also ich gehe mal davon aus die wend schon den kram eingespielt haben aber für je nach anwendung ist es halt
Keine gute also je nachdem hast du halt entweder performance einbußen oder sicherheitsprobleme also
Eigentlich würde ich sagen gut für
Server anbieter die epic verwenden
Die haben nämlich das problem nicht
Was ist das für ein trend mit not hot
Es gibt wirklich jemanden im internet der den scheiß noch nicht mitgekriegt hat also
Wo ist wo ein farbischen man fährt abgestellt ich bin übrigens vergesstlich ey
Da unten abgestellt
Also es gibt glaube ich irgendwie denn was ist das ein englischer komiker der so auf rapper macht
Und der hat halt ein video aufgenommen wie er da
Einen seiner songs vor vorgetragen hat im studio und das song hat halt
Einmal irgendwie den ganz lustigen text und merkwürdige geräusche und seitdem geht halt das ganze internet darauf ab du suche suche einfach mal
men mens not hot auf auf youtube
Wir können wenn ihr wollt können wir uns
Da wo wir uns ich muss jetzt eh hoch ich ich muss jetzt eh hoch reiten hier
Dings hier spott wir können wenn ihr wollt können wir uns mens noch dort mal zusammen angucken
Guck mal warum nicht
Sind die bei die textur mal video immer schwammig
Bei bdo die texturen an sich sind eigentlich gar nicht so übel ich muss mal kurz gucken auf was ich es gestellt habe ich glaube ich hab's auf hoch
Ja texture die texturen an sich sind gar nicht so schlecht wenn man hier mal guckt das problem ist einmal
Meine naja gut das ist jetzt erst echt mega kacke ne aber es gibt welche die sind echt ganz ok ja aber das problem ist dass bdo
Übelste übelste sachen einploppen das ist das was scheiße aussieht
Ich meine das hat bestimmt jetzt nicht die besten texturen oder so das game aber guckt mal nach dahinten wie die bäume da aufploppen und so
quickmuffs
Nice ich weiß zwar nicht was ich damit genau mache
Ich hab da ganz viele
Gifts gift gifts immer immer gut nice nice gifts
Big schag also weil weil es ja noch nicht kennst
Während ich reise bin ich immer gut
Ich weiß gar nicht was ich damit genau mache
Das ist einfach aber b Sponge Bob
Das bekannteste dürfte das hier sein
Moment ich bin zu spät im video ja das bekannteste ist wahrscheinlich das hier
so das ist ja das ist so das bekannteste aus diesem ganzen men's not hot big
shack zeug und das kam so gut an dass da halt zig leute irgendwelche
mime bilder und gedunst gemacht haben sonn jetzt ist halt keiner hot der cool
sein will weil er ist halt auch cool und nicht hot es hat übrigens für mich eine
ganze weile gedauert bis ich das gecheckt habe das mensch not hot quasi
eine umschreibung dafür ist dass er cool ist irgendwie war ich in diesem in
dieser in dieser rap denkweise so war ich nicht so richtig drinnen
irgendwann alles ständig erleuchtet ist not hot weil er halt so cool ist
ein x-buch ist ausgelaufen so wir kreiten uns jetzt hier oben wir machen
jetzt daily daily wie man im moment also wir machen daily jetzt da und da und
eventuell da also im prinzip einfach auf dieser ecke hier fangen wir mit mit der
daily hier an würde ich sagen oder mit komm wir fangen mit der base mit der
basi mit der basi daily fangen wir an
ich sehe gerade das video also ich glaube ich glaube man stream der ruckelt nicht
das ist einfach bdo das ruckelt wenn ich das so mal wenn ich das jetzt richtig
sehe ich gucke nämlich gerade auf meine stream vorschaue
ne das stream ist flüssig das ist einfach bdo was ruckelt als halt bdo was
willst du machen
füttern wir mal den china farmer den pleb und den rng stream wenn ich hab's
gesehen es ruckelt nicht das ist einfach bdo was kurz ruckelt bdo hast halt
einfach auch mal fremd props von 144 auf 35 das bestimmt meldaun das bestimmt
der wind aus meldaun fix es muss so sein
war ja vorher aber bdo noch nie
auf fack was mit meinem stream los da fack moment ich muss mal ein audio
interfaz rausziehen das klingt mega das klingt aber richtig kaputt was ist das
was ist das aber vor allem auf meinem auf meinem streaming rechner ist ist der
winder sound kann übelst am abkacken aber aber richtig am abkacken das hört
ihr nicht seid froh dass ihr das nicht hört das ist auf dem anderen rechner
es ist ja gar nicht mein streaming rechner das war jetzt falsch ausgedrückt da wo
ich halt während ich hier auf dem rechner spiele internet fast gucken kann
chat habe und sowas ist der sound kaputt das hört sich an wie irgendwie wie eine
ente in slow motion der sound
der muss jetzt mal neu starten
spielst du den full ad max ja klar
immer jetzt geht das auch wieder ja wie genau die studio 28 genau so hat sich das
angehört genauso genauso wie du das gerade geschrieben hat aber jetzt ist das
auch wieder ok
schlechtes matchmaking aufwacht schlägt an meldaun was ist das eigentlich für
gedudel im hintergrund das ist best of hiro yama
nie hier ruma der japaner spricht ist wahrscheinlich hier oma oder so aus
japaner sprechen das alles so geil aus so zack ich hier oma weiß ich weiß ich
über den typ ausspricht also ist etwas entspannteres wir können ja auch
man muss mal raussuchen
wir lassen ich lasse die musik jetzt erst mal das ist irgendwie schon
entspannung genauer ganz bestimmt 1 max hast du eine ahnung ob man mit 250
obfhörer niemand fürs zocken benutzt beziehungsweise allgemein für pc eine
zusätzliche soundkarte beziehungsweise kopfhörer verstärker benötigt bei
seinem pc kommt auf deine soundkarte an bei den meisten on board soundkarten
würde ich mal vermuten das ist
ich habe es noch nie ausprobiert ehrlich gesagt aber ich würde mal sagen wenn
was rauskommt ist es nicht so geil
wahrscheinlich viel zu leise also einem iphone kannst du es definitiv vergessen
zu betreiben ganz komplett kommt gar nichts raus
ich habe hier einen an meiner headset wand habe ich noch einen akg 701 da muss
mal kurz gucken wie viel widerstand der hat 62 so und der hat am der hat an
smartphones und tablets schon richtige probleme ich habe in einer on board
soundkarte aber noch nicht ausprobiert also ich könnte mir vorstellen wenn du
ein mit 250 hast das da aus der on board sound kann wenn mal zu viel rauskommt da
schon ein kopfhörer verstärkern ein bisschen wums nicht verkehrt wäre so
mal je nach on board soundkarte sind da ja auch die art digital analog wand ja
wandler und sowas nicht unbedingt die besten und isoliert ist es auch nicht
gut aber da gibt es richtig krasse qualitätsunterschiede zwischen den
mainboards und es gibt mittlerweile auch ganz gute
die dt 770 nehmt die klein dann kannst du es auf jeden fall überall dran
betreiben
höhe hartbumsen gesagt kann auch fisten sagen dumm fisten
hey max ich habe gerade ein wett gesehen ist echt super habs als
obertechnik lub eigentlich gut verstanden das freut mich zu hören
weil ich war ja schon ein bisschen geknickt über das video muss ich sagen
also beziehungsweise dass ich gleich mal in sind die abos gekriegt habe
mal gucken mal gucken wie es heute heute morgen früh aussieht mit abos die ich
bekommen habe es schwankt aktuell aktuell kriege ich aber es kriege der
abos jetzt bin ich wieder auf insgesamt nur minus vier es kann wieder ein paar
dabei keine ahnung aber auf der anderen seite ich meine vielleicht
vielleicht wird das video ja mal wirklich in ich habe es extra in diese
diese diese technik und dings wie heißt diese kategorie science and technology
oder so gesetzt auf youtube wissenschaft und technik genau
trifft ja ganz gut und vielleicht habe ich ja glück und
irgendjemand bei youtube stell fest das ist vom content her gar nicht so schlecht
und empfiehlt das ein bisschen
das ist baro ist auch da easy clap
genauso wie optik jellyfisch das acht ich würde mir auch eine ein ordentlichen
verstärker holen oder eben den kopfhörer mit mit niedriger wie sagen
sie dazu in pendanz also mit niedrigeren widerstand den unterschied wirst du
nicht so viel hören ich will so gar nicht hören
bin ich jetzt ein starr
ich bin da ich kann dailies machen ja wir finden eigentlich das thumbnail ich
finde das thumbnail vom neuen video ist irgendwie schick das ist das das sieht
gut aus ja das ist nicht übelst überzogen irgendwie mit roten kreisen so
aber ich denke trotzdem dass es dazu an regt drauf zu klicken
so quest unsubscribing max heißt die quest easy machen wir hier das bei
hier ist richtig was da steht das einzige was noch dazu gekommen ist dass
ich jetzt meine waffe mal all die meldet ab aber das beste ist habe ich
euch ja noch gar nicht gezeigt hier
es gibt wieder neue gilded rewards ok und pils oder was ist das
kuku in pet hier gibt stande easy dande gibt's hier habe ich 70 siehls zusammen
quasi am 17 wenn ich das richtig gerechnet habe sind eigentlich alle
quest daily nein nein nein es sind nicht alle quest daily es gibt es gibt weekly
quest daily quest und auch einmalige quests pro charakter einmalig soweit ich
weiß oder ja doch muss pro charakter ja ja muss pro charakter sein es gibt die
main quest ist definitiv pro charakter
brauche ich jetzt critical hit rate
max ftw i das ist ein guter name warum i war max ftw schon belegt
schreibt das video ist großartig hab es gut verstanden aber welches genie kommt
bitte darauf dass es das ist jedes mal faszinierend wie die leute die
sicherheit umgehen also da drauf zu kommen ist echt geil
ich meine an sich ist an sich ist ja nichts verkehrt das funktioniert ja
alles so wie gedacht das design ist halt scheiße
deswegen hat linus auch klein mal wieder schön interne geflammt das kann er ja
gut leute flay aber die finden können das generell gut leute flaym
das ist eine scheiße es funktioniert ja prinzipiell alles wie gedacht
du kommst ja nur drauf indem du misst was schnellere zugriffszeiten hat
kicks not hot teemo never hot
kann ich noch so viel t-shirts an und ausziehen
der einzige der hot ist ist der wizard
das ist übrigens lustig finde man diese daily quest ich soll basis killen aber
ich kann nicht irgendwelche anderen fischer killen die auch basis sind aber
offensichtlich keine sind das ist aber bdo logik da muss man muss man nichts
drauf geben was soll man als normaler bob gegen die
exploits der cpu unternehmen patches installieren man muss halt sagen die
patches sind halt nur workaround zu wirklich fixen können das nur die
hersteller
und die work arounds führen halt dazu dass bei intel cpus bisschen performance
einbußen gibt aber bei den meisten sachen ist das rechtlich nicht damit
dass das großartige auswirkung haben wird was ich mich übrigens frage ist
müssen wir mal nachrechnen ich weil wenn prinzipiell die speicherverwaltung
geändert wird könnte das durchaus auch amd betreffen also sprich dass dadurch
dass ein intel bug umgangen wird auch amd cpus langsamer sind es sei denn man
hat eine abfrage eingebaut also sprich wenn amd cpu drinne ist dann aktiviert
man das nicht dann muss man halt beide verfahren pflegen
der fräscher ist am start von easy basi kreit also eigentlich ist es easy daily
quest
aber easy als ich war da verbinden wir ja zwei gute sachen wenn man verbindet
easy basi kreit mit easy daily quest ich muss gucken ob ich die abos gekriegt
habe das triggert mich übelst gerade ich habe wieder welche dazu jetzt bin ich
bei plus minus null wieder hat mich jemand zufällig abonniert aus dem
stream gerade vielleicht kommt es ja jetzt vielleicht kommt es jetzt ja von
hier weil ich hier gerade rum geheult habe wie scheiße das ist
thx timo timo timo wahrscheinlich eher sind amd cpus also jetzt besser als die
von intel das da ändert sich nix dran also wenn du ganz spezielle anwendungen
hast dann vielleicht sind können auch also wenn du eine anwendung hast wo
früher der cpu schneller war und das so ein grenzfall ist könnte sich dann da
lohnen aber bei spielen werden auch nach wie vor
intel cpus die aktuelle generation ja noch schneller sein als amd bei den
meisten spiel kommste anzeige ist raus gleich gleich gibt es in die bann
disabo gibt es dann hier
übrigens das war jetzt die erste woche wo ich wieder arbeiten gehen musste und
was ich bei mir witzig finde ist jedes mal jedes mal wenn ich lange urlaub
habe und ich habe macht es ja jedes jahr so ich habe ja jedes jahr quasi den
ganzen oder fast den ganzen decemberurlaub jedes mal denke ich mir
dann so boah du hast überhaupt keinen bock nächste woche auf die arbeit zu
gehen absolut nun und überlegt man hat immer ein komm mach doch hier mal
lasst den scheiß doch und mach mal hier dein online zeug professionell aber ich
entscheide mich dann doch jedes mal dagegen was auch die was auch reale was
auch so rational gesehen die bessere entscheidung ist also nicht unbedingt
wegen der kohle sondern weil es einfach
teilweise gezwungen wird dann und so bin ich in beiden sachen ziemlich
entspannt weil ich mal so weiß ich wenn ich gar nichts mehr auf youtube machen
will habe ich immer noch genug geld erstens habe ich genug gespart zweitens
gehe ich arbeiten für tage und kriegt noch genug und auf der arbeit bin ich
entspannt weil ich mir denke ihr könnt mich alle mal wenn es mir auf den sack
geht deswegen total bescheuert aber das jedes mal wenn ich langen urlaub habe
ich habe dich abonniert deine werbung eben war nicht schlecht
da hat so was gebracht hier ich muss mir angewöhnen ich muss ich muss
regelmäßig ich muss regelmäßig sehr laut machen
ich muss ich muss alle ich muss alle stunden hier im stream mal drauf
hinweisen so nach dem motto und wenn ihr immer auf dem aktuellsten stand sein
wollte dann folgt mir doch auf twitter auf youtube auf was weiß ich so was
so wie es die richtig die richtigen sellout pros machen und ich brauche
noch t-shirts und energy drinks und was braucht was brauchen wir noch alles so
für richtigen für maximalen sellout was ist denn da so angesagt schamm
haarsch mittel haarsch mittel brauche ich also eigentlich ist max max schampo
und die glocke für die notifikation die max handyhülle alles alles brauche ich
ich kann ich könnte echt das ist eine gute idee
max ftw dass ich könnte es den nightbot so einmal in der stunde spammen lassen
einen song ja da habe ich ja schon den passenden frankfurter produzent am start
hier der macht das
heute ist es egal ob du singen kannst geschweige denn ob du ob du rappen kannst
das ist wurscht nicht nicht weil es die musik besser macht oder so aber es juckt
ein hauptmusik gut ist oder nicht
das sind ja keine möbse zum baschen basis sind auch noch gar nicht fertig
warum gehe ich hier raus patreon das habe ich mir schon überlegt das habe ich
mir schon überlegt ob ich das machen soll weil das ist ein guter weg ohne dass
ich jetzt irgendwie noch zusätzlich g2 a sellout oder so in so ein mist machen
muss g2 a habe ich ja gesagt habe ich kein bock mehr das war wirklich eine
ganz gute geschichte habe ich mir schon überlegt ob ich das nicht machen soll
aber erkennt mich ja wenn ich mir so was überlege dauert es immer ewig bis ich
das mal machen also wirklich ewig snapchat ich habe ich habe noch nicht mal snapchat
ich kann kein snapchat sellout machen ich habe ja ich habe ja auch nur facebook
weil das nicht weil ich facebook geil finde oder irgendwie auf facebook
großartig was was machen will sondern einfach nur weil das mit die
einfachste möglichkeit ist viele leute zu erreichen und ich habe ich habe schon
so oft in videos gesagt ich kenne niemand der facebook gut findet also
facebook irgendwie verwendet jeder facebook weil halt viele leute bei
facebook sind aber keiner benutzt gerne facebook und ganz viele leute machen das
auch so auf sparflamme mittlerweile so nach dem motto facebook wenn doch noch
irgendeiner was will aber ja alle kein bock mehr auf facebook bin ich froh
dass ich mit dem scheiß nie angefangen habe facebook ist der größte shit
überhaupt er braucht kein mensch und nervt eigentlich nur
mittlerweile auch gleich ja ich kenne viele sagen vieles ich lese es immer
oft dass leute einfach facebook kommt weg was ich noch nie verstanden habe ist
warum warum es snapchat gibt wahrscheinlich ist die einzige
daseinsberechtigung von snapchat aktuell weil es snapchat filter gibt und dass
die leute irgendwie lustig finden wozu braucht man snapchat ich meine jetzt ich
meine die frage jetzt wirklich ernst ich will keinen flamen der snapchat
verwendet wozu ist das also ursprünglich war das ja mal dass dass man
nachrichten quasi löschen konnte in anführungsstrichen also sprich dass man
dass man schwanz bilder und hinten bilder verschicken konnte und sich
eingeht das im prinzip das aus der fabian kratz schreibt erkennt sich da
anscheinend aus und dass man denken konnte sie werden gelöscht ich meine
sie waren hier weg aber man hat gedacht sie sind weg
ja das ist der einzige grund der mir auch einfällt dass ich leute nackt
bilder schicken können aber anscheinend verwenden ja auch viele leute so snapchat
und ich weiß warum also was hat warum gibt es das
also ich muss sagen seit es discord gibt sind meine sämtlichen chat und
chat video telefonie telefonie aufnahmesachen mit mehreren leuten sind
alle mit discord wunderbar ab abgefackelt ja wenn du so fragst verstehe
ich gar nicht warum es der chat benutzt ja ich glaube das wissen viele
irgendwie nicht so also ich habe mich frag mich ich meine das ernst ich
frage mich echt was man da was man damit macht also warum es das gibt
weil vor allem warum sich das so durchgesetzt hat
ja genau das kenne ich auch die leute die snapchat filter verwenden und
irgendwie denken das wäre die oberkrasse bild bearbeitung
auf snapchat sind die meisten grills ach so das ist natürlich den grund das
kann man verstehen wenn man da auf der suche ist ich dachte bei tinder sind die
meisten grills übrigens ich habe letztens gesehen es gibt auch das das
kappa pride gegen stück von tinder nennt sich grinder und und wissen aber
ich habe ich habe auch noch was schönes letztens auf twitter gesehen von von
einer feministin die hat oder das jetzt kommen wir das ist ja ganz ganz
thema wo gleich hier wieder alle sich aufregen können von einer
feministin die hat die hat gesagt sie schreibt nicht mehr das wort womann
sondern sie schreibt womann weil im wort womann steckt men drinnen und sie
verwendet das wort sie will keine wörter verwenden wo mentren vorkommt
dementsprechend ist womann ja absolut schon quasi grenzwertig sexistisch
das muss man sich mal vorstellen die leute haben echt probleme ich meine wenn
man sich vorstellt dass man das ich meine so schreibt man das was soll das
sein das hört sich an wie wie wie ein mop in in bdo ja was kreineste heute
wominen das konnte man jetzt auch auf zwei arten versteht so war es gar nicht gedacht
ach ja und könnt könnt könnt ihr euch noch an diesen skandal um tracer
erinnern als als rausgekommen ist dass tracer lesbisch ist in diesem einen
weihnachtskomik von overwatch kann sich ja noch jemand dran erinnern
das war letztes jahr letztes letztes jahr zu weihnachten ist einen
overwatch weihnachtskomik rausgekommen wo man gesehen hat dass tracer eine
freundin hat also eine womine quasi und da war natürlich glaube die haben dann
auch rumgeknut geküsst im comic und da war halt klar tracer ist gay
und man könnte jetzt ja denken dass das begrüßt wird dass dann viele sagen
boar blizzard irgendwie mutig finde ich gut dass quasi euer euer aushänge
schild dass das ihr quasi sagt hey die ist lesbisch eigentlich eigentlich
hätte ich gedacht dass dann eben die die sich immer so was immer aufregen dass
sie das gut finden so und wisst ihr was das argument war warum das nicht gut
ist das finde ich ist so hängen geblieben das kann ich nicht wirklich
nachvollziehen sie haben sich da drüber beschwert dass tracer ein ein charakter
ist der explizit für das männliche auge designt ist und dann ist es schlecht
das hätten sie jetzt saria genommen hätten sie sich beschwert so nach dem
motto ja ja wieder die ganz wieder die alten stereotypischen sachen ausgepackte
hate hate hate nimmt man tracer so quasi eines der aushänge schilder und
quasi hübschesten charakteren auf erwartet dann ist das auch nicht weil
das explizit was männliche auge designt ist also jetzt gibt echt leute die
können sich den ganzen tag über alles aufregen
ich habe das gefühl da geht es auch schon lange nicht mehr irgendwie um
gleichberechtigung sondern einfach sich aufzuregen
saria ist viel attraktiver als tracer sache immer jedem das seine tracer
müsste auch nicht sein mei mei ist bestes overwatch grill
mei ist beste alles von allen overwatch grills ist da ist mei eindeutig mein favorit
und mich wundert es nicht dass das erste was es zu overwatch gegeben hat so
quasi an nennen wir es mal fan content irgendwelche pons man das wundert mich
überhaupt gar nicht ja doch während der beta was max steht auf dicke mädchen
nähe ich sag mal so es muss ja immer passen und ich meine ich bin jetzt nicht
mega fett oder so ich bin auch nicht das schlankste muss das muss das muss ja
schon passen zusammen
und mei ist halt mei ist top da kann man nichts gegen sein
thick genau super thick am besten am besten sam may immer noch aus in diesem
animations in diesem short film das haben sie echt gut hingekriegt wie viele
basis muss ich eigentlich noch killen letzter basis basis ist die life
ich gucke jetzt mal ich muss jetzt mal in die comments von meinem video ob da
jetzt ob da jetzt irgendwie wieder wieder der rechtschreib flamer wieder am
start ist von vorher
so dann geben markt west abgeben verfahren habe ich das jetzt richtig
ausgesprochen eigentlich west geht das
aber ein quest geht nicht muss man so west
aber quest back mit der freund autorun autorun fell war quest ist die sich aber
minecraft sind nicht egal oder das muss mal heißen na wegfindung
um jetzt mal dieses etwas merkwürdige thema um dem noch was hinzuzufügen
neben mei finde ich in overwatch finde ich auch noch wer fast an mehr rankommt
in overwatch ist anna
allerdings habe ich habe jetzt absichtlich mal pause gemacht
allerdings mit dem mit dem mit dem junge anna skin
kann man in bdo alle skillen oder sollte man sich für bestimmte skills
entscheiden du kannst prinzipiell alle skillen wenn du genug punkte hast also
du wirst früher oder später genug punkte haben aber das dauert du musst
ganz schön klein und wirklich alle skillen zu können und ich würde von ich
würde eigentlich gar nicht so sehr meine punkte aus dem fenster hauen aber du
kannst bis 55 soweit ich weiß kannst du skillen wie du willst mit 55 also bis
55 oder war 56 weiß ich was kannst du um skillen
heißt du kannst eigentlich ausprobieren weil ab 56 kriegst du noch eine zweite
skilllinie also aktuell hast du ja nur die hier main und dann kriegst du noch
awakening und du musst eigentlich hauptsächlich erst mal das hier skillen
in awakening ist dass du brauchst damit 56 auch ordentlich viele skill points von
diesen normalen skills hat man da nur noch ein paar außer halt die die richtig
viele skillpunkte haben und die richtig krassen pvp rockstar sind die haben auch
von den alten skills noch mehr und 80 hotbars so wir haben quest abgegeben dann
können wir jetzt katri spot reiten oder wir gehen am besten ins katri spot
da hatte ich der friseur mit dem spiel angesteckt es geht ich bin ja ich bin
halt der übelste bdo casual und vor allem was mich jetzt ein bisschen
motiviert auch wenn ich täglich aber fast täglich halt mein daily und ein
bisschen rum zu kreiten und sowas ist halt weil ich streamen kann
sendt aber best meins nicht macht aber sendt aber quests
das ist halt viel viel entspannter also erstens glaube ich zum zugucken ist
bdo relativ entspannt dass jetzt das ist jetzt ja im prinzip kein overwatch
wo permanent irgendwas ist oder bettel viel oder so relativ entspannt außer es
kommen wieder irgendwelche nur berseys wie letztens am gaha spot das war das
war der echtes war der größte kack besser den ich gesehen habe der war so
schlecht der war so schlecht ich meine ich habe überhaupt keine moves gemacht
im endeffekt und der typ muss man sich vorstellen wenn wenn das der bersi ist
hier oder der busch hier ist der bersi das stand einfach rum und ich bin auf
ihn zugelaufen habe meine kraft haste gedrückt hat sich nicht bewegt obwohl
berseys eigentlich somit die besten movement fähigkeiten hat das war ich
denn das habe ich so nicht das habe ich noch nicht gesehen weißt du was das für
einer war keine was das eigentlich von eiken alles mein pet vor allem warum
wird das geht das weg wenn man drauf klinkt
wähle gaben als präsident und es wird kein dritten weltkrieg geben
der der jetzt ist nicht schlecht erinnert sich noch jemand an den half
life 2 source code dieb stahl
dealing kd habe habe gerade ein video gesehen war alles echt
ne moment ich ich kann nicht lesen ich bin rib reading skills habe gerade dein
melk daun video gesehen war alles echt gut erklärt meine frage jetzt wie
denkst du wird sich jetzt der markt entwickeln bezüglich inter und amd der
inter chef hat ja schon einige aktien verkauft
ich glaube dass wir das mal keinen großen unterschied machen die anwendung
wo inter aktuell schneller ist mit inter wahrscheinlich auch schneller
bleiben als bei der aktuellen generation trotz trotz diesen back jetzt als
sei denn sind irgendwelche grenzwertigen sachen wie datenbank oder so mounting
skills dann nicht für die für die zukunft also wenn wenn amd da jetzt noch
ein bisschen obendrauf legt also ich glaube nicht dass es so viele
einflüsse haben wird ehrlich gesagt
glaube das wird die welt sehr schnell vergessen nein das wird die welt nicht
vergessen die welt wird zwar vergessen dass es da mal eine sicherheitslücke
und probleme gegeben hat aber die welt wird schlechte benchmark ergebnisse
weiterhin sehen für intel cpus je nach benchmark ja je nachdem was die
benchmarks machen und ich hoffe jetzt mal dass einige seiten vielleicht den
ein oder anderen benchmark reinnehmen der so skal intensiver ist und wenn man
das macht dann sieht man in zukunft immer weiter das intel beschissene
benchmark ergebnis hatte auch vollkommen zurecht stand
sentauer besch schlechte benchmarks monka ist ja wenn man jetzt mal angenommen
man macht einen datenbank benchmark oder sowas ist was ja gar nicht mal so
abwegig ist ja das testet die auteste cpu lasst alles mögliche kann man ja
machen dort könnte es durchaus sein dass amd auch wenn sie vielleicht
normalerweise jetzt langsamer gewesen während intel abhängen werden zu einem
günstigeren preis
weißt du zufällig in real world war real world use case der sehr intensiv ist
ihr datenbank zum beispiel also es ist kalt im prinzip ist in zus kalt ja alles
wo du mehr rechte brauchst also sei es jetzt zugriff auf
netzwerk und und i o und so was in der richtung brauche ja für fast alles in
was jetzt halt nicht rein rein userseitig zu berechnen ist also spiele haben da die
wenigsten probleme mit moment ich glaube übelst übelst hängen wo laufe ich denn
eigentlich lang da mussten
ja also datenbank ist ein scenario könnte ich mir gut vorstellen
er kann das sein dass ich gerade übelst die orientierung irgendwie verloren
habe ich glaube ich laufe jetzt einfach in dem marken
so ja ich bin die falsche richtung gerannt auf berg hoch da da berg
stellts
die erste richtig gute erklärung die ich gefunden habe ja finde ich nämlich
auch ich will also wie gesagt zur eigenlob stink und so was in der richtung
aber das ist der grund warum ich das video gemacht habe ich habe ganz die
meisten einträge auf den news seiten waren einfach kacke die haben alles in
einen topf geschrieben und alle haben nur geschrieben oder es ist schlimm und
oder es hat irgendwas mit speicher adressen zu tun und irgendwie sowas aber
so wirklich was das problem ist das hat kaum eine newsseite geschrieben und ich
habe auch auf youtube mal ein paar videos geguckt die haben auch alle mehr oder
weniger nur das vorgelesen ja schlicht ergreift alle keine ahnung wovon sie
eigentlich reden das kann doch nicht sein dass ich da
einzige bin den interessiert was da eigentlich genau passiert
deswegen habe ich das video auch gemacht
wenn mini mini centaurs gebäscht die nur da sind dass nubs die nach grenz
bazaar reiten nicht geohnt werden
der x-men
da ist er
ich hoffe ich gefällt heute ein bisschen entspanntere musik
weiß einer von euch eigentlich ob wirklich exklusiv inter betroffen ist
also bei amd ist es ziemlich sicher dass sie nicht davon betroffen sind sie
sagen sie führen sowas nicht nicht nicht out of order aus was quasi andere
privileg erfordert
haben keine ahnung ehrlich gesagt es war jetzt nicht unbedingt richt es war jetzt
nicht wirklich intel spezifisch also da ist jetzt nichts drinne wo man sagt hey
das ist was wo man quasi inter interne sachen für kennen muss oder so es ist
eher bei amd einfach besser implementiert also das kann durchaus
sein dass abends gleiche probleme hat ich wollte eigentlich auf den berg hoch
fällt mir so auf kommt auch noch ein video zu spektrum
ist ja wie lange ich gebraucht habe bis ich gecheckt habe was da eigentlich
genau passiert
also ich meine das ist die eine sache ob man ob man versteht prinzipiell was
die schreiben und es dann auch irgendwie zusammenhangen bringt also es ist jetzt
ja auch nicht wirklich so simpel
mit dem loser piste schalte es leckt mega leck
wo laufe ich hier eigentlich gerade total beknackt ich sollte
es leckt ultra leck
was ist denn das
ich glaube jetzt mal zum spot und guck mal irgendwann noch das chat noch
geschrieben du hast ja gesagt die meisten patches werden die tabelle aus
den prozessen rausnehmen könnten die prozesse nicht einfach die adressen
brute force wenn die dann eine passende adresse finden würden wäre immer noch
mehr können sie nicht können sie nicht weil der teil der virtuelle adresse zu
echten adressen auflegt auflöst kennt diese adressen für diesen prozess nicht
das bringt ja nichts wenn du es durch probierst du kannst alle deine
virtuellen adressen ausprobieren diese adressen werden nie für deinen prozess
aufgelöst zu echten adressen nie weil es nicht drinnen steht weil es nicht
gemapt ist
man macht es ja hauptsächlich aus performance gründen dass man es eben in
jedem prozess mebt allerdings nur den zugriff verbietet das ist ja auch
irgendwo sinnvoll da musste nicht jedes mal ein ganzes zeug umschreiben und
löschen
allerdings halt nur wenn inter das richtig gemacht hätte
weil wenn man jetzt das problem hat bleibt mir eigentlich kaum was übrig
außer fix einzubauen und ich mein eigentlich ist es ja der richtige
ansatz eigentlich ist es so wie sie es jetzt machen wollen dass es erst gar
nicht gemapt ist das ist ja eigentlich der richtige ansatz dass das klingt viel
sauberer als dieses gefuddel was wir vorher gemacht haben
aber dazu braucht es halt hardware unterstützung dass du eben nicht so viel
mehr aufwandt hast dadurch
deswegen jetzt auch nicht auf speichern von anderen prozessen genau und deswegen
muss ja auch bei jedem kontext switch alt alt wenn wenn dann prozess halt jetzt
in anderen prozess bearbeitet oder anderen strett bearbeitet muss dieses
ganze ding dann ausgetauscht werden
diese ganze loge diese ganze diese ganze auflösungstabelle muss dann ausgetauscht
werden das dauert halt weil um für den nächsten prozess die tabelle quasi zu
laden muss du da muss du deine kompletten gespeicherten tabellen für
alle prozesse durchgehen und die zusammen bauen und dann reinschreiben und
dann switchen deswegen ist ja ein kontext switch auch so teuer und wird jetzt
noch teurer
früher waren halt wenigstens kornel aufrufe ziemlich billig dadurch weil in
jedem prozess einfach das gleiche reingemapt war und da musste nichts
umgeschrieben werden sondern nur dass für den jeweiligen prozess
so viel ist aber dazu
sie ist max was ist so das ergebnis bei den benchmarks also wenn ich ohne dass
ich mir angeguckt habe ich vermute mal dass bei games wahrscheinlich sich das
in der messungenauigkeit bewegt vielleicht bei den ein oder anderen
spielen die wenn man die auf niedrige detail stellt und quasi maximal cpu
auslastung provoziert dann minimal also wirklich minimal würde ich jetzt
erwarten was spielen bei so sachen wie prime 95 und sowas würde ich sagen gar
nichts null
das ding rechne ich ja rein user seit ich und halt bei iow intensiveren
sachen also auf heilsservern und sowas würde ich sagen hat man ein bisschen
einbußen
fast fast absolut gleich ja wird mich auch wundern wenn ich das sind wirklich
grenzfälle wo du da großartig performance einbußen durch hast
also die regeln ist es nicht
wisst ihr was das beste ist morgen ist freitag
das ist sehr sehr nice
so übrigens wenn jemand noch andere andere themen hat könnt ihr gerne den
chat schreiben also ich muss mich jetzt nicht da einen ganzen abend über das
zeug auslassen für die vergisst nicht dann ne box zu sehen
ja stimmt ja muss ich noch machen da muss mir level eins mystik erstellen
bis das mache ich jetzt machen jetzt gleich noch marsch mit mystik level 14
mystik ja das mache ich jetzt mache ich jetzt gleich nach der daily hier
level 14 mystik erstellen und bock stellen
die box beim wizard hier
ja schon ber sie
andere andere teile vorsätze 2080 keine vorsätze das bringt nichts dass ich
finde das ganze dieses vorsätze zu jahresbeginn ist eigentlich verkehrt wenn
man irgendwie was merkt was scheiße ist und man hat also man hat verstanden dass
man das ändern sollte und hat auch quasi so die so die überzeugung dass es gut
ist wenn man das ändert dann ist es ja bescheuert darauf zu warten bis das jahr
anfängt man kann damit einfach anfangen ich meine es gibt genug genug sachen von
denen man weiß dass es nicht gut ist aber man hat nicht genug antrieb sie zu
ändern das wird halt der jahresanfang 2018 auch nicht ändern
also zum beispiel eine sache die ich letztes jahr gemerkt habe ich meine ich
werde auch nicht jünger aber man muss auf der anderen seite aber so 33 sind
jetzt auch nicht kurz um abkratzen aber das ist schon so ein alter wo man wo man
manche sachen mehr merkt die man halt früher nicht so gemerkt hat zum
beispiel dass wenn ich lange vorm rechner sitzt das mit der rücken weh tut
und so was hatte ich früher alles nicht so ich habe halt gemerkt wenn ich auf
der arbeit den ganzen tag rumhocke und ich habe jetzt da glücklicherweise und
so einen krassen steh schreibtisch also auf der arbeit und daheim wenn ich den
ganzen tag auf der arbeit rumhocke plus noch konzentriert auf den rechner
gucken was daheim dann quasi noch am rechner was mache dass das auf dauer habe
ich da bekommt mir das nicht so gut deswegen habe ich mich jetzt dazu
durchgerungen dass ich jetzt morgens und abends quasi früher aussteigen auf die
arbeit laufe beziehungsweise von der arbeit zurück zum bahnhof laufe das sind
so ungefähr ja wenn du langsam bist 35 bis 40 minuten aber da muss schon
wirklich langsam sein normal läuft eher eine halbe stunde da hast du da bin ich
halt morgens mal ein bisschen bisschen wenigstens bin ich gerade in die wüste
gelaufen
ja ich halte morgens mal wenigstens halbe stunde den weg zum mittag und das
hat schon was gebracht
wissen wir mal also was ich halt gemerkt habe ist dadurch wenn ich mich so
richtig wenig bewegt habe und viel vom rechner gesessen hat was halt auch nicht
ausbleibt wenn man eben so was arbeitet wie ich und jetzt noch youtube und
twitch und gedöns macht was ich gemerkt habe ist irgendwie dass ich das ganz
ganz ganz schwierig zu beschreiben so ich war viel unaufmerksamer und
schwierig zu zu beschreiben so ein bisschen so ein bisschen so wie als als
ist man so ein bisschen benommen im kopf wisst ihr weiß ich ob die beschreibung
jetzt so gepasst als ist mir ein bisschen benommen im kopf und nicht so
richtig bei der sache und als so so so ein bisschen so als ist man so ein bisschen
ein bisschen benebelt einfach ja
so und seit ich da das wenigstens jetzt hin und zurück laufen mach jeden tag auch
bei wind und wetter und das habe ich auch nicht zu 2018 angefangen sondern
als ich halt gemerkt habe dass das was bringt vorsatz war halt gewesen ich mach
weiter aber das hätte ich auch so ohne 2018 gemacht
deswegen ich denke vorsatz brauchen wir nicht wie war dein silvester
geh mal oben bei mir aufs profil und in videos
da siehst du was ich an silvester gemacht habe
wie kommt dass du jetzt bdo streams kommt das öfters das kam ja schon relativ oft
das ist super entspannt ich kann endlich mal wieder mit dem fabian was
zusammenspielen und das game ist ja auch nicht übel
so ich muss jetzt noch 14 der mystik machen
bdo ist auch echt entspannt zum anscheinend ja finde ich auch
max was sagst du denn zu den sicherheitslücken von inter warst du
heute schon mal bei youtube bei mir bei mir auf dem channel im ori
wachs wegen dir hab ich wieder mit bdo angefangen weswegen hast du aufgehört
weil das game ist halt auch nicht für jeden was warst auch nicht bei mir auf
youtube ja gehen wir bei mir auf youtube gucken weil ich habe genau dazu heute
was hochgeladen
wo krebs ich hier eigentlich rum das ist der und effektivste klein aller
zeiten hier der fabian kriegt wahrscheinlich anfälle wenn er das sieht wie ich die einzelnen
ob special nicht optimal ist genug ich wusste ich wusste ich wusste ich kenne
ich wusste dass du dich aufregst ich kann mir das so richtig vorstellen
den da ups dahin
ja das ist dann da noch 100 bärsas bär ja bärsas vielleicht auch
zentauers und dann machen sie mystik auf level 14 das dauert 15 minuten oder so
bringen sie nach velia und machen die awakening box auf und selten das ding
dann für money easy money
ne ne ne mori denn du musst ein cpu nicht zurückschicken dass es gibt
eigentlich wenig sinn also ich meine es gibt jetzt ja patches für winnows und so
und die geschwindigkeit einbußen halten sich echt den grenzen vor allem für
spiele dürften sie kaum existieren allerdings auf der anderen seite ist
halt ein 7700 alte alte generation also vielleicht kauf sie lieber nach
1700 jetzt unabhängig von melda und er ist auch von melda betroffen aber ist
die bessere cpu weil sechs kerne und neue generationen
und ich glaube reichlich nimmt sich gar nicht so viel
brauch sein auch neues mainboard teurer teures mainboard
aber wenn es nur wegen melda und ist für dich nichts nicht zurückschicken
spart man die scharkato sie lieber oder was holt man sich davon wollte mir
dann ne box holen aber ist gestern die dande gesniped keine ahnung was man sich
dann davon holen sollte wenn man eine dande schon hat aber ich würde sie auf
jeden fall aufheben weil von den ersten wir können gleich mal gucken was es da
gibt aber die ersten paar sachen waren soweit ich weiß nicht sondern ich toll
auch das fährt nicht dann lieber irgendwie abgekraten schmuck oder so
was ich werde mir in 14 tagen eine dande holen für ein wissert wenn ich die
nicht vorher noch irgendwie gesniped kriege glaube ich aber nicht
der f da sind sie ausgewischen die bahn warum sage ich die basis das sind
überhaupt nicht die basis halt bdo mobs alles gleiche
ich würde jetzt aber nicht quasi also wenn ich mir jetzt ein rechner
zusammengestellt hätte würde ich nicht jetzt ist das ende und großartig
v.a. wenn es für gaming ist weil wenn ich mit wenn ich mich von 8700 k z.b.
entschieden habt bringt es nix zu sagen deswegen wegen melter und hol ich mir
jetzt ein amd weil man hat sich ja bewusst dafür entschieden für 8700 k
weil er in game schneller ist als amd und das ist ja immer noch
ok die rotation ist zu klein wo rotierst denn hier am besten
das habe ich ganz viele leuten auch unter den unter den videos auf youtube
gesagt na viele haben gesagt da ich hol mir jetzt ein 7700 weil 8700 nicht
lieferbar ist ich finde das ist eine der wenigen situationen wo es sinn gemacht
hat tatsächlich mal zu warten mit dem hart verkauf
normalerweise sage ich ja kauft euch immer das wenn ihr was braucht allerdings
geht es ja da meistens darum dass man nicht darauf warten soll bis etwas
neues vorgestellt wird und aber das war ja schon vorgestellt und man wusste ja
quasi was sache ist und dass es besser ist und da hätte man schon mal eine
woche warten können oder oder einen monat aber den 7700 ist natürlich immer
noch super cpu so einmal noch rauf dann müssten wir alle haben quest abgeben
oder level 14 müsste ich erstellen oder farben was meinst level 14 macht sinn
oder mache ich auf level 14 haben wir theoretisch noch ein feld deckt schaue
weil ob ich jetzt level 14 mache oder ob ich direkt nach velia rennen macht jetzt
zeitlich auch kein allzu großen unterschied
das dauert 15 minuten
jetzt erst fack litt litt und jetzt erst fack
ich glaube ich habe heute auf der arbeit einverwirrt der ist schon ein
bisschen älter muss man sagen hat es auch nicht mit so mit zu internet slang
ausdrücken man hat mich heute angeschrieben hat so
gemeint hier max wo ist dann das testsystem dafür habe ich gesagt das
testsystem gibt es nicht mehr das haben die tippen kaputt gemacht den das
gehört und ist halt weg und gibt es demnächst noch nicht mehr hat also
gemeint ja und wo soll ich das jetzt testen etwa auf dem life system da habe
ich halt gar nichts drauf geschrieben einfach nur gesagt jolo und dann hat
er dann hat er nichts mehr geantwortet also gar null ja dann nur geantwortet und
irgendwann als ihn später später gesehen habe hat er mich so ganz komisch
anguckt sie irgendwie so was voll zu einschätzen von mir
da kann man Leute noch mit verwirren mit sowas
ich meine jolo jolo ist mittlerweile die abkürzung kennt doch jeder
ja die neuen cpus gehen nur mit z370 es kommt irgendwann demnächst jetzt und
demnächst ist den bar bei intel wissen wir ja auch wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
günstigere plattform dafür aber da wünscht jetzt beispielsweise nicht
drauf waren es gibt doch auch relativ günstige also ich meine du kriegst um die
120 euro schon in super z370 sport das ist zwar immer noch teuer im
vergleich zu anderen mainboards aber dafür hat mehr best ever
der braucht schon einen neuen shop wieso ich benutze auf der arbeit total viel
internet slang ich dachte auch manchmal geflamed und so was das gucken so
manchmal immer dass er was will er jetzt wieder
ich dachte auf erworts heute wer sagt denn sowas habe ich das gesagt
ich habe placement schon gemacht 8 zu 2 und ich habe festgestellt was stand auf
youtube ich habe auf youtube heute nicht gepostet dass ich
ich bin verwirrt ich habe auf youtube heute nichts gepostet dass ich auch
mal was streben hast du vielleicht einen post gesehen der der ein bisschen älter
kann es sein weil das letzte was ich gepostet habe war gestern das heute das
loot boxen video kommt das loot boxen video kam heute aber nicht weil ich das
über intel cpus machen wollte das habe ich vor zwei wochen geschrieben mit
overwatch rang
ne ne ne ne max also serious max wenn wenn die leute glaube ich die haben
es da mittlerweile schon eingestellt dass ich da sehr viel internet zeugs laber
ich sag ja auch manchmal irgendwie sowas flamet euch nicht oder irgendwie
sonst aber die meisten sind ja auch ein bisschen jünger und spielen selbst
hast du mal final fantasy gespielt ich habe so viele final fantasy schon
gespielt so jetzt machen wir uns mystic mystic bis level 14
in ich entgegen mystic bis level 14 um dann ne box zu verkaufen
ist es fack
warst du schon mal im dark net oder ist es eine frage also sieb ich habe ich
habe schon tor verwendet aber ich habe jetzt nicht explizit nach irgendwelchen
illegalen sachen da geguckt so
habe ich dann die box gesagt nee den blauen box dann wäre schön ja wenn ich
dann den box hätte ja so mystic wo ist er wo ist er ist das mystic grill da ist
er diese anzeigen hier unten erinnern mich
irgendwie an die waffen stats in call of duty früher die sind wahrscheinlich
genauso fail was steht beim wizard da wo ist er denn haben die eigentlich das
gleiche ich ich ich glaube ich glaube bis weil die wissen selber nicht was er da
eintragen so was versteht man wissert
an der wissert ist jetzt auch standardmäßig jung wie es aussieht aha
was auch immer ok create der von 14 mystic machen wir jetzt gar nicht viel gar
nicht viel zeugs hier sondern karakter nehmen
gebetet overrated sowohl moment wo liegt man das er hält noch mal
dieses menü ist übelst
moment kann man nicht overrated schreiben das ist zu lang
fack und gebetet outdated besser
ja bupfysik aber das ist das muss das ist ein koreanisches beziehungsweise
asiatisches mmo da ist da ist das das erste was was irgendwie geht und in bdo
ist es ja noch halbwegs realistisch ja nicht wie in anderen gelten
tommys gibt sagen das muss man nicht unbedingt jeden aufgetrückt
nein nein kein tutorial please please keine no ich bin was
oh starting npc soll ich finden egal ich bäche jetzt erstmal ein paar mobs
und quest warte
wahrscheinlich aus dem streben
So
hat
Ja Fabian das ist wirklich ganz schlimm also wie gesagt ich werde jetzt auch nur noch
nur noch Wommin sagen anstatt Wommin weil alles andere ist sonst zu sexistisch
so jetzt machen wir mal ein typisches gequest einfach so schnell wie es geht
der bunt
sehnlose killtasks machen also jetzt seht ihr mal für alle die irgendwie auch neu bei BDO sind
wie einfach das leveln ist ich meine nicht dass die ersten 14 level in MMOs sonderlich schwierig
aber das ist mittlerweile mega schnell guck mal beim beim level 6
guck mal seht ihr seht ihr wie die xp da hochspringt zwei mobs gekillt schon level 6 so
die musik ist gerade ein bisschen kaputt ja ich mach die main quest bis 14 das geht halt übelst
schnell der snacks der erste der mal das pc kommando auf anhieb weiß und und benutzt
ansonsten kommen ja dann ausrufe zeichen hw ausrufe zeichen hardware ausrufe zeichen spex
oder sonst was aber ausrufe zeichen pc so ist richtig
ausrufe zeichen bboards irgendwann mache ich mal ich hab noch so ich habe noch so g2a karts
mit mit code mit codes drauf wo man dann was kaufen kann da mache ich immer mal raffle stream
dann gehen sie alle ab ausrufe zeichen raffle das wollte ich schon immer mal dass es die
leute bei mir spam das mache ich auch bei jeder gelegenheit nicht weil es was gibt
sondern weil es halt damit schön schon rollen kann irgendwie auf ich habe gerad klickt ich
right click immer noch next kriege ich jetzt auf einmal so viele so viele views denken
sie alle ich mache jetzt müssen aber denkt ihr jetzt müsste ich reroll oder habe ich
den haus gekriegt oder sowas moment muss ich mal nachgucken ist irgendjemand gehostet
nö kommen doch grad irgendwie viele und wollen meinen level 14 mystik sehen den ich nur
angelegt habe für feldstacks und box verkaufen
was klatschen muss das leute klatschen muss es
kann man mit einer 1050 ti 60 fps 720 p stream cpu encoding easy easy kannst du das machen
je nach cpu kannst du auch cpu encoding easy machen was ich sogar empfehlen würde weil
das sieht in der regel besser aus
übrigens leute nächsten stream werde ich mal versuchen 900 p zu streamen das müsste
ich eigentlich auf den gleichen quality settings mit meiner cpu noch gut packen
hallo und herzlich willkommen bei eure max fps
macht er eigentlich noch macht er kriege noch call of duty videos ich habe lange nicht
mehr geguckt das letzte mal wo ich was gesehen habe hat er irgendwie so einen tauchgang gefilmt
hallo kann mich in der deutscher hören
gibt es ja auch pizzer giveaways das mache ich irgendwann mal wenn mich in den pizzerladen
sponsoren will
die quests sind zu dumm
aber mit einer gtx 1060 er wie gesagt kommt darauf an ob du ob du cpu encoding machen
willst oder hast du das schon geschrieben mit was willst mit was willst du entkommen
wenn du mit der grafikkarte entkommen willst ist überhaupt kein ding mit mit fast keiner
weil das da ist ein extra encoder für drinnen das ist für die gaming performance dann
kaum kaum oder gar keine beeinträchtigung
es haut aber ganz schön in die tast
hat man nicht mittlerweile eigentlich mal gesehen max in meinen videos nicht in anderen videos
bin ich ein bisschen im hintergrund rumgelaufen
das war zu jamie
glaube dass du hast du hast das komplett falsch verstanden ich das gemeint habe mit was möchtest
du deinen stream encoden nicht coden
möchtest du das mit der grafikkarte machen oder möchtest du das mit der cpu machen
das ist im endeffekt in obs einfach nur ein anderes häkchen setzen
cp gpu encoding ist halt für für die performance besser sieht schlechter aus und ja gut cpu
den das umgedreht
100 euro donation vor allem vor allem wenn du das donaten würdest
du weißt ja also weißt ja eh schon außerdem wenn du das donaten würdest dann wird es
gar nichts geben weil ich glaube ich krieg noch geld
mach dir mal kannst du dich noch daran erinnern ob wir das alles jetzt ob das alles geklärt
ist oder ob da noch was offen ist ich glaube nämlich wir haben das das letzte mal verschoben
wegen anderen sachen und ich krieg noch was
da muss man mal drüber labern dann im discord ich kann mich nämlich auch nicht mehr so richtig
dran erinnern
ich weiß es auch nicht mehr wir müssen uns da mal zusammen Gedanken drüber machen und
ich muss mal ich gucke mal auf konto auszügen ob ich irgendwas finde ich glaube 100 euro
ich könnte keine ahnung lasse einfach morgen noch mal oder irgendwann überlegen da kommen
wir bestimmt wieder drauf
ich glaube auch da war noch was offen
so haben wir es jetzt hier bald
moment was mache ich denn hier ist total Blödsinn
ja ich wie gesagt ich weiß ja ich merke mir das auch nicht aber das da fällt uns schon
wieder ein
so jetzt gehen wir zur princess of serendia da ist sie die sind warum haben wir die jetzt
genau hier sitzt
die ja rette es hört sich irgendwie ein bisschen an wie yogo rette finde ich
so easy schon sind wir fertig das war's mehr muss man nicht machen ist jetzt dann auch
hier die
diese eine quest muss man nicht machen wenn man sich einen neuen char erstellt für für
failstacks und für gedöns was man so braucht in velia
aber bis zu dieser quest muss man machen weil ab dieser quest kann man erst entschalten
bist du nicht der sachse
der osten meldet sich zurück ne der torsten meldet sich zurück was stimmt ja stimmt ja
ich bin nicht der sachse
ich höre mich da absolut 060 an oder
das ist mein richtig aktueller pc auf dem ich hier gerade spiele und striebe
der ist doch geil der pc da kann man überhaupt nichts dagegen sagen also die komponenten
sind wirklich alle erste sahne was besseres wirst du zum spiel nicht finden aktuell über
den rgb raum kann man sich streiten
so jetzt haben wir die quest dann rennen wir jetzt mal nach velia
verkaufen die box
autorun nicht gemapt ok
rgb raum triggert schon immer ganz ehrlich es gibt so viel unsinnige sachen mit rgb beleuchtung
mittlerweile da ist rgb raum noch die die zwar genauso unsinnig ist wie alles andere aber
die sitzt wenigstens schön zentral im rechner und kann dann alles beleuchten dann brauchst
du nur eine sache mit rgb beleuchtung
weiß jemand wie man knowledge über das schatten krab bekommt findet dazu nichts und will das
tracks fragezeichen endlich weg bekommen ich weiß doch nicht mal wo das schatten krab
ist ich kann dir einen tipp geben was ganz praktisch ist wenn du das game auf englisch
stellst kriegst du den begriff raus wie das auf englisch heißt da kannst du falls du
schon gegoogelt hast nichts gefunden hast ja stell das game auf englisch guck dir an
wie der begriff auf englisch heißt und gibt das gibt das in google ein dann findest du
es gibt eigentlich für jeden ort für jeden npc für jede quest für bdo eine seite wo
du dann sehen kannst was du machen musst
könntest du eventuell noch mal ein video zu dem 120 144 165 240 herz monitor machen
habe ich gemacht ich habe es aufgenommen ich habe es aber ich habe noch kein video draus
gemacht hat eigentlich gar nicht vor das hochzuladen
und generell also es empfiehlt sich bdo auf englisch zu spielen ich meine das muss nicht
sein also wenn er wenn er das jetzt irgendwie nicht nicht liegt oder du sagst es ist einfach
angenehm ein deutsch zu spielen kann man das auch machen aber man findet viele sachen
viel viel einfacher wenn es auf auf englisch ist
muss kann man was gucken nebenbei während ich hier lang jogge
ist ein schneller hier es müsste es müsste grill ein bisschen schneller ran
ist zwischen watchtower und klisch zwar gucken ob ich das habe
klisch war das hier unten
das das da
habe ich das was du meinst
watchtower ist da und klisch swamp ist da und dazwischen zwischen ist doch eigentlich
gar nichts
ach so da gibt es auch unterschiedliche panels also wenn das wenn das alles schnell genug
ist natürlich viel besser
also es schon unterschied was blickwinkel abhängigkeit sowas anbelangt
kann es sein dass bdo ein bisschen hinterher ist mit weihnachten
sieht man nur auf der minimap und nicht auf der großen karte dann keine ahnung da muss
man aber irgendwie bei vias diese bdo atlas seite oder so gucken
ok dann gehen wir mal zum wald holen unsere kiste raus und verkaufen
ja wie protest der typ sah wirklich gruselig aus
so habe ich das beim berser drin oder wo habe ich diese diese komische awakening kiste da
jetzt rumliegen
mein account ist so unordentlich ich müsste es alles mal aufräumen
hier kommt mal easy schokato siehens
fünf noch dann gibt es da eine box
ich glaube ich habe es beim bersi ich glaube ich habe es auf dem bersi
so der bersi hat es der bersi hier noch irgendwo liegen da da ist es
awakening weapon box
endlich mal ein ort den du von bdo kennst das coole an bdo ist dass alles halbwegs bevölkert
ist
also das ist nach velia kommst du halt so schnell aber nach velia gehst du auch immer
wieder hin
800 euro ist schon mal eine hausnummer für den bildschirm ich werde mir erst einen neuen
bildschirm kaufen wenn es dann wenn es die diese 4k 144 herz hdr gsync dinger gibt die
sind zwar schweine teuer aber da hat man wenigstens aber was ordentlich neues
bisschen was wo es jetzt abgehält wo man das halt spürt
so wird mal schön von 9 millionen verkauft jetzt
die
Werden die IPS oder TN sein? Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, ich hoff mal IPS.
Das ist dann auch mal ein bisschen Upgrade.
Das Scheiß soll 1800 Euro kosten für den Monitor. Null.
Muss ich mal gucken.
Ob ich da nicht irgendein Deal aushandeln kann. Mit ASUS.
Dass ich so einen kriege und dann irgendwie irgendwas damit mache.
Übrigens Leute, es heißt ASUS, muss man auch nochmal dazu sagen.
Und nicht ACES, wie das die Amis sagen.
Das finden die nicht toll.
ASUS ist okay, aber ASUS finden sie aber allerbesten.
So, Leute. Debated. Wir sind fertig.
Alles gemacht, was ich machen wollte.
Und ich muss ja auch im Prinzip in einer halben Stunde schon pennen.
Gibt es irgendeinen, den wir hosten können?
Mal her.
Ich gucke gerade bei den Leuten, die ich abonniert habe, ob es da irgendeinen gibt.
Gehört man nach Hause?
Sehe ich jetzt eigentlich keinen von denen, die ich abonniert habe.
Und die meisten, die ich jetzt draußen könnte, haben eh schon 5000 Zuschauer.
Wie wäre es mit Social Sleeping?
Ist ja schon fast so, Alter.
Die Detox, ASUS sagt nein.
Ich vermute, ASUS sagt nicht nein.
Also ich wollte mit ASUS ja schon mal was machen.
Und ich habe da nichts gefunden letztendlich, was ich haben möchte.
Haben sie gemeint, das ist auch noch nie vorgekommen?
Haben wir uns darauf geeinigt?
Wenn ich was finde, sage ich Ihnen nochmal Bescheid.
Und jetzt ist es soweit.
Zielkrampf, Zielkrampf können wir hosten, ja.
Das machen wir.
Okay Leute, ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream oder im nächsten Video.
Wenn ihr nicht auf YouTube gewesen seid, heute und mal ein neues Video angeguckt habt,
dann könnt ihr ja mal gucken, ich habe etwas hochgeladen,
zur aktuellen Intel CPU Lücke, zum aktuellen Intel CPU Bug.
Und falls ihr mich nur von Twitch kennt, dann guckt mal über YouTube vorbei
oder folgt mir auf Twitter.
Da gibt es auch immer die neuesten Sachen und dummes Gelaber von mir.
Das heißt, wem das hier nicht reicht,
der kann sich auch noch die volle Ladung auf YouTube oder auf Twitter geben.
Und ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen, macht es gut, bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss.
Tschüss.